c'est à quelques centaines de mètres
d'ici aux alentours de migennes dans une
zone non habitée que le corps d'un homme
a été retrouvé dans le canal de
bourgogne
d'après les premiers éléments de
l'enquète la victime était âgée d'une
vingtaine d'années la macabre découverte
a été faite ce matin vers 10h30 par une
cycliste qui se promenait le long du
canal
elle roulait elle a découvert des traces
de sang sur le sur le chemin de halage
elle s'est arrêtée était interloquée
et elle a regardé dans l'eau dans le
canal il a découvert un corps inanimé
alors c'est à côté d'une ligne de chemin
de fer qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce
que c'est une personne qui longeait est
une des chemins de fer qui a été touché
par un train qui est tituber qui est
tombé dans l'eau est ce que c'est un
règlement de compte ça arrive partout
d'après les informations communiquées
par le parquet d'auxerre la victime a
été retrouvée les mains ligotées une
enquête pour des faits d'homicide
volontaire a été ouverte
l' enquête a été confiée à la section de
recherches de dijon ainsi qu'à la
brigade de recherche de sens pour
l'heure l'identité de la victime n'a pas
encore été établie une autopsie devrait
avoir lieu demain en fin de matinée